Der name dieser killerpilze ist eigentlich ziemlich harmlos kann die doris heißen die hefepilze
Aber sie sind tödlich und sie treiben gerade ihr unwesen auf der ganzen welt
solchen zentralen warnen vor diesen killer keim und tatsächlich die opfer sind diesen pilzen wehrlos ausgesetzt wegen
dieser pilze mussten bereits ganze
intensivstationen geschlossen werden und sie sind wirklich ziemlich mysteriös denn eine untersuchung der pilze sorgte für ein sehr sehr
Seltsames ergebnis woher die killer keime kommen und warum behörden weltweit so machtlos sind jetzt in klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Zum ersten mal entdeckt wurden die hefepilze kann die doris durch einen
Abstrich einer japanischen patienten das war im jahr 2009 und seitdem sind die pilze tatsächlich nicht mehr zu stoppen nur wenige zeit später
hatten sich die pilze bereits nach südkorea kuwait
südafrika indien und auch in die usa ausgebreitet und
forschungsteams weltweit und behörden können nicht viel mehr als hilflos zusehen feststeht kann die
Doris hat es besonders auf menschen mit schwachem immunsystem
abgesehen die opfer sind also zum großteil patienten und patientinnen in krankenhäuser wenn das immunsystem
gesunder menschen schafft es die pilze abzuwehren schlimmer dagegen trifft es die ohnehin geschwächten opfer die
todesraten liegen achtung zwischen 50 und 70 prozent
Doch kann man oft nicht
genau sagen ob die killerpilze den tod der schwerkranken menschen tatsächlich
Verursacht haben oder eben nur beschleunigt und obwohl uns kann dieser auch es bereits seit 2009 bekannt ist sind
medizinerinnen und mediziner weltweit quasi machtlos wenn die killer keime sind zum einen sehr schwer zu identifizieren
Und zum anderen sind sie resistent gegen fast alle mittel die man ansonsten
gegenkandidat infektionen einsetzt 2016 schlug die amerikanische gesundheitsbehörde centers for disease control and prevention cdc
Dann alarm bis dahin gab es bereits sieben fälle in den usa von denen vier tödlich
Geendet war mittlerweile sind
174 infektionen in zehn us bundesstaat bekannt und in großbritannien mussten bereits komplett
Intensivstationen geschlossen werden mehr als 200 menschen sind dort an kann dieser auch es erkrankt einen großen ausbruch gab es
2015 16 in einem medizinischen zentrum für herzchirurgie in london
im vergangenen september reagierte dann auch das robert-koch-institut hier in deutschland und rief zu erhöhter
aufmerksamkeit bei candida auris fällen auf dass die hefepilze in deutschland bislang nur in einzelfällen
nachgewiesen wurden liegt nach einschätzung des robert-koch-instituts wohl auch daran dass sich die
identifizierung von candida auris in routine labor schwierig gestaltete deswegen sei von einer untererfassung
auszugehen zumindest ein erfolgserlebnis kann die forscher jedoch
Im kampf gegen die killerpilze verkünden und zwar wurde mittlerweile das erbgut entziffert doch auch dabei hielt kann dieser auges
überraschung für die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler bereit das ist wirklich sensationell zum einen konnte in keiner pilz probe die vor
2009 archiviert wurde eine spur des kindercamps nachgewiesen werden das ist tatsächlich ein hinweis dauern zwar ein sehr starker
Dass diese hefepilze tatsächlich erst. Im jahr 2009 entstanden sind kurz bevor die ärzte diese pilze
Im ohr der japanischen patientin das erste mal aufgespürt hatten bei vielen erregern ist das anders sie verbreiten sich lange zeit ohne erkannt zu werden
Die große ungelöste frage die über allem steht woher kommt kann die da aus und warum
bricht diese
Pilzinfektion gerade jetzt aus bisher gibt es keine antworten sondern nur indizien fest steht jedenfalls
pilze sorgen immer wieder für verheerende solchen beim menschen aber auch bei
unterschiedlichen tieren wie bienen fröschen oder
fledermäusen überrascht sind forschungsteams weltweit, zudem von einer weiteren
erkenntnisse und das ist wirklich ziemlich verrückt die gen sequenz zeigt nämlich dass dieser killerpilze gleich vier
mal unabhängig voneinander geboren worden sein muss und zwar etwa zeitgleich die unterschiede der verschiedenen stämme des pilzes sind
Einfach zu groß als dass sie von ein und demselben uhr an stammen könnten
dieser umstand lässt uns fragen was genau dafür gesorgt hat dass solche pilze vor etwa zehn jahren gleich mehrfach
Zeitgleich aufgetaucht sind teams aus mikrobiologen und biologin hoffen jetzt dass die antwort auf die frage
gleichzeitig auch hinweise darauf liefern wird wie man kann dieses stoppen kann sein
bleibt den labors und medizinischen zentren nur eins übrig sich besser auf die hefepilze vorzubereiten
datenbanken müssen aktualisiert werden und
medizinisches fachpersonal muss geschult werden damit zumindest gewährleistet wird dass die killerpilze als solche diagnostiziert
Werden können ja und jetzt kommt noch etwas besonderes wenn ihr als
Allererstes neues zum thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann meldet euch hier bei
Whatsapp an denn dann erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom neuesten video garantieren ihr könnt direkt neben vorschläge machen oder
Andere ideen vorschlagen der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken so jetzt haben sich acht übrigens schon
2000 angemeldet und ich habe wirklich jede nachricht beantwortet aber bitte nur wichtige nachrichten schreiben und hier geht es weiter mit dafür drauf klickt ein
außerirdisches leben leben entsteht viel früher als angenommen ansonsten bis dann
Bleibt dran wir sehen uns auf whatsapp also hören schreiben und so weit ihr wisst schon